hey Millie how are you
hi how you doing I am doing great hey
congratulations on the sequel It's so
good I just want to know with all the
success on that first movie what's it
like for you having kids come up to you
and say they want to be anola homes
I mean it's a huge
honor to be able to be that for some
kids
um especially my younger sister it feels
insane because like my character is so
much she looks up to which is hilarious
because I'm her sister but it is an
incredible honor to be able to be a part
of something that means something to so
many
I was just talking to Henry Cavill and
he said you two really act like brother
and sister when you're on set but that
you make fun of him more than he makes
fun of you so I just want to know what
is so fun about teasing Henry on set
um well he's an introvert um and I'm not
so uh that in itself I just tease him on
my loudness and
um and uh I just make him really
uncomfortable which is what I'm good at
you know I just like I'm very loud and I
I am I like to sing a lot and I like to
talk to him about reality dating shows
and he's just not interested which makes
me and that's me teasing him and in a
very well that's like that's like stage
one for me like we haven't even got to
staged at 10 it's like it's like a the
process yeah I love that well speaking
of singing it looked like you had a
blast at the Enola homes to Premiere
Mariah Carey was there there's this
photo view too and it kind of looks like
you're singing together did you sing
with her at the premiere no I didn't I
really didn't I was
no no sound was coming out
and she was doing the same I love that
what's it like having her support at the
premiere
oh amazing I mean she's the busiest
woman so for how to take the time out to
come and see it it was a dream come true
I love that am I too greedy to want a
duet album with you too
who who's am I too greedy is it me I
would love you two to pair up and do a
duet album together
I mean
well I'm currently hope but I you know I
am well we will see we will see I mean
schedule schedule you know it's like
it's like people like they're so hungry
everybody's so groovy to just chill out
I said it last night but I mean I would
really
I'm not even gonna say it you know it's
a crazy thing to say I want to have a
duet album with Mariah car it's like
it's like just let her let her thrive in
her own I mean she's been thriving and
before I was born so I love that
um you know when you're working on this
and you're producing this what was the
main goal going into the sequel what did
you want to deliver to the fans
I just wanted to deliver a true and
authentic story about a real thing I
think uh just educating people on
you know
women's rights being able to focus in on
a specific and real story about female
workers in in labor Industries and
protecting their rights it's been it was
a really important message for me to get
that delivered uh you are such a rock
star in this so nice getting to talk to
you thanks so much
thank you bye